with the handover of stolen and looted
art works in the news European ministers
are sent to discuss proposals for new
rules on the return of cultural objects
unlawfully removed from a member state
the aim of the proposals is to ensure
that any national treasures such as art
or archaeological findings are swiftly
and efficiently returned to their
country of origin to this purpose they
broaden the definition of national
treasures extend return deadlines and
place the burden of proof on the
possessor of the works of art when it
comes to compensation at the meeting in
Brussels the council will also address
media freedom and pluralism which the EU
considers to be one of the pillars of
democracy there are three key issues
transparency of media ownership ensuring
that journalists are free from political
influence and that their sources are
protected and the independence of
audio-visual regulators The ministers
will also hold a public debate on the
issue of governance in sport their talks
at a focus on the framework and culture
influencing the way that a sports body
sets up its policy and rules monitors
performance handles risk and reports on
its activities good governance in sport
is an increasingly important issue and
is considered to be a precondition for
self-regulation by sports organizations